[Music]
those are the bells ringing at st
peter's basilica in rome last christmas
day
whether it's coming from the vatican or
your local house of worship
the sound of bell's ringing is indelible
as dana jacobson found out those
reverberations
continue to resonate with us after
centuries of technological advances
proving that bells are definitely here
to stay
for more than a century the striking of
clappers against the side of these
bronze bells
has been ringing vibrations across upper
montclair new jersey
oftentimes churches don't have real
bells
in their bell tower
there's a speaker that plays an
electronic sound that sounds like a bell
sean price is the director of music
ministries at st
james episcopal church so it's very
special to me to have
actual real bells playing all the time
this has to be different yeah it's truly
a hands-on approach
price is a classically trained
harpsichordist but to learn how to
tickle
these keys he had to take his training
up to a whole new level
there's a console set up on the second
floor of the tower
[Music]
where i'm pushing a lever that's
attached to a cord
that's then attached to a pulley system
that moves the clapper
that hits the side of the bell
earlier this year that intricate system
which feeds the 11 bells above
needed to be repaired
[Music]
and it's no wonder the bells have been
in use ever since they were installed by
the mcshane bell company
the bells were cast in 1918 june 11th
is when the ledger was written
when james android acquired the mcshane
foundry last year
he took possession of the company's
ledgers that date back to 1870.
the interesting thing is these bells
were actually shipped via b o railroad
some will say canal so if they went on
the erie canal
or by boat the details for st james
include the note each bell was tuned to
along with the type of bolt used and
total weight of each bell
unfortunately we don't know how much
they cost and some of the original
ledgers do
show what each bell was charged for
one float i used to tell people that if
my wife and i both rode
harley-davidson's that would cost more
than what i had in my bell collection
still neil geppinger says he's spent
tens of thousands of dollars amassing a
collection of bells
big
and small well at his peak i've had more
than 60.
i must still have maybe 45 right now
what do we love about bells and the
sound of bells
well they have a beautiful tone
geppinger bought his first bells as a
way to call for his young children on
their family farm in iowa
just as his mother had done for him i
didn't start out loving mills that i
acquired my first two good job
and then i found i really enjoyed the
sound of church belts
as his collection of bells grew so did
his interest in their history
four years ago geppinger cataloged his
vast collection
in a self-published book large bells of
america
a history of bells and the foundries
that made them
because the sound carries so far they've
been used for
alarm use fires in more modern days
locomotives anything where you needed to
get people's attention
[Music]
geppinger says large bells date back to
400 a.d
when they were used to call people to
church
he traces the earliest foundries in
america to paul revere
who used bronze recycled from cannons to
make bells after the revolutionary war
geppinger still owns one of revere's
bells it's one of just a few
he's holding on to the rest are for sale
[Applause]
my favorite bell of my collection from
the standpoint of the sound
is a 39 inch diameter machine it's just
got a gorgeous tone
they cast their bells just a little
thicker than their competitors did
it'll hold its hung out for a full
minute it's pretty special
music to the ears of james android
the idea is to grow the company back
into what it once was
and to get the name back out there so
people really realize
what is there and what kind of bell they
may have had in their tower
with over a hundred thousand bells cast
around the u.s and parts of the world
we're within a throwing distance of one
of our bells she has the ability to
strike them or swing them and with
modern technology
programming about anywhere in the world
is just a few clicks away
so right now this system is in
leonardstown maryland and while it all
sounds good demand for new bells isn't
exactly what it used to be
three years ago white chapel great
britain's oldest bell foundry which
manufactured america's liberty bell
closed its doors in the united
states it's down to a small number of
foundries that include
verdan in cincinnati and the st
louis-based mcshane
so is this a disappearing art form then
casting bells while it is a disappearing
art form i don't think it will
fully go away i think there will still
be
the need for bells and the want for that
and the beauty of it
like in upper montclair new jersey where
sean price has been playing for
15 minutes at noon each day since the
start of the pandemic
the bell tower built to honor the town's
world war one veterans
now serving another purpose there are
certain sounds that bring people back to
a time in their life that
may seem a little happier perhaps
especially during the pandemic this
music has really inspired people
it's given people hope and it's given
people
something to listen to and look out for
every day
[Music]
bell's ringing the rest of the day no
and i'm okay with that yes
he must be very good one wrong note and
it's all over